please welcome ej williams
you know i don't know why but first
question out of the gate is i was
thinking about fred and i doing like a
saturday night live which was a show
that we loved growing up um and i still
love to this day because it's the
greatest institution is there like a
bucket list thing or something you want
to just that you want to do
um
that's a great question um
for me it's a lot of different things
you know i'm somebody on sat i'm telling
jokes all the time so for me something
uh as much as people don't like it i
still do it anyway is try my hardest to
do some more comedy you know um stand up
i love stand up yeah yeah comedians are
a national treasure for sure they really
are they're medicine comedy is how i get
through life for sure and humor
is an antidote for sure to the hard
stuff i mean i think laughter and crying
are twins almost for sure i mean i mean
theater made it the logo you know
exactly thank you duh comedy and tragedy
thank you ej
exactly i mean that lick literally is an
artist mascot is the comedy and tragedy
faces thank you you might have just made
sense of life for me
no problem no problem um okay so when
this got presented to you as doing this
show what was like some of the first
things that came into your mind
it was more like a what is this in terms
of how would i be able to pull this off
and for that part you know um at the
time when i got it i was 11 and i know
i'm only 12 now it doesn't really make a
difference um but
it was it was it was crazy because you
know with the with the weighing heavily
story with it you know how is a how is
an 11 year old going to pull this off
and for me
once i was able to figure out why i was
doing it
what how much it actually meant um and
for me knowing my personal beliefs in
terms of how i feel about the things in
the time putting that all into one
perspective was great and me being able
to show it on camera just helped it even
more yeah you're i mean you're 12
going on 20. like i know
40 year olds who seem way less mature
than you
i mean the way you speak is it's like
that's the way an adult speaks and i
look at my kids i was your age when i
was like working and
i can't get you in your pajamas
it's such a bizarre weird i have my kids
are the same thing my kids i can see
what i was doing when i was the age of
these kids you know of my kids and i'm
like
man
find your shoes bro like
do you know what i was had to do when i
was
[Applause]
were you doing this will you roll the
commercial please
what's this without sugar or additives
goodbye fred hello pikmin
a better choice
can you stand that was my first job
that was your very first
that was my very first job that was for
pac-man vitamins it was my very first
job and that literally
like
started
everything like i don't know if you guys
could identify the talent in that right
there
i don't know if people like that is
that's it that's guys would be here for
40 years but um it was enough to get me
here when you find people sit next to
you drew so that that started it
but ej you know when you're casting like
you said like you've had this experience
as a young young person you know uh in
front of the camera and you have to be
good you know but also if what you're
doing is your cuteness that's gonna go
away you know so we need to find someone
that was good ej's incredibly
intelligent i mean so he brings a
soulfulness to this role that
people just don't have at 11 or 12 years
old i think there was so much on your
guys shoulders too like you were
carrying a lot of people through growing
up and
adults through important themes and
times in history
and yet didn't both of you have your
first kiss on the show
i'm like deep important themes and your
first kiss
yes
okay ej how was that
okay look out oh gosh
okay you're going to work that day
and you're like today's the day
um it was uh it was kind of awkward that
two weeks um very very awkward i want to
say um the only thing that made it weird
was as soon as i met her i had to kiss
her i haven't i hadn't met her at all
that day so i'm coming to work like all
right it's just another day i'm probably
going to see everybody anyway no that's
not what it was at all i come to set and
i come in have no idea who she is i've
never met her from before and uh hi uh i
have to kiss you now
um and it was it was it was awkward in
that way but when it comes to actually
doing it you know um it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't bad it wasn't
[Laughter]
it wasn't it wasn't bad you know um i'm
i'm definitely somebody who's in a
comfortability so if i'm not comfortable
i'm not going to do it and
i was pretty comfortable so i was like
you know and now
you have a beautiful little record of it
i do i do so which is so sweet like a
photo album a moving photo album of that
moment fred your first kiss
on the wonder years right yes yes first
kiss on the wonder years uh
i knew her a little bit more we shot
that towards the end of the pilot that
was the very first episode so i knew
danica a little bit better than than um
ej uh knew milan uh but um you treated
it kind of just like any other scene you
didn't like make it too important you
didn't try to make it too casual it's
just like okay so you're gonna do this
then you guys are gonna kiss and the
camera's gonna move and so it was very
like you know it wasn't full of romance
you know it was very almost you will you
know
and you know it is fun to have a record
of your very first kiss it is fun i have
a record yes yes okay um so i cannot
thank you guys enough for putting this
show
these shows on the air
[Music]